[音樂]
想想看，雲端一個小小的設定
錯誤會多麼迅速地演變
成重大的安全事件。
暴露在網路上的儲存帳戶、
為快速測試而啟動的未打補丁的伺服器
，或是悄悄開始
洩漏敏感資料的 API。
在混合多雲環境中，這些
漏洞可能很難被發現，直到
攻擊者先發現它們。
讓我向您介紹一門課程，
您將透過這門課程學習如何利用 Microsoft Defender for Cloud 來
改善您的
安全態勢、保護工作負載
並應對威脅，從而應對這些現實世界的場景
。
您好，歡迎光臨。很高興您加入
我們。我是傑夫·漢薩克，
一名微軟技術培訓師。在本
課程中，我們將介紹學習路徑五：
使用 Microsoft
Defender for Cloud 來緩解威脅。
我們將一起了解 Microsoft Defender
for Cloud 是什麼，如何啟用它，如何
將 Azure 和非 Azure 資產連接到
它，
如何使用
安全性評分和建議等姿態管理功能，
哪些工作負載可以受到保護，以及
最後，如何回應和自動
修復安全警報。到
最後，您將知道如何將 Defender
for Cloud 變成實用的日常
工具，以降低風險並加快
調查和回應速度。
那麼，就讓我們開始今天的課程。  在
這裡，我們為更廣泛的目標奠定了基礎
，即
使用微軟安全營運
平台來防禦網路威脅。
我們將重點放在
第五條學習路徑，其目標是
使用 Defender for Cloud 來緩解威脅
。本學習路徑旨在
幫助您從了解情況到採取行動，
從而加強您的雲端安全態勢，並
在發生可疑情況時做出有效應對
。
讓我們來看看
整個學習路徑將涵蓋哪些內容。
我們將首先
使用 Microsoft Defender for
Cloud 來規劃雲端工作負載保護。然後我們將連接 Azure 資產，
並引入非 Azure 資產
，以便您了解 Defender for
Cloud 如何支援混合雲和多雲
環境。
接下來，我們將使用
安全評分、建議和合
規性洞察等工具來管理雲端安全態勢。  接下來，我們將介紹
Defender for Cloud 中提供的工作負載保護功能。  最後，我們將介紹如何使用 Defender for
Cloud 來
修復和
回應安全警報。
現在，讓我們開始規劃雲端工作負載
保護。
在啟用所有功能之前，最好先
了解 Defender for Cloud 的
實際功能、
它可以提供的保護類型以及這些
保護如何與您正在執行的工作負載相符。
本單元的目標很
簡單。首先，您將能夠
描述 Microsoft Defender for Cloud 的功能。
其次，您將能夠
解釋
Defender for Cloud 中提供的工作負載保護功能。第三，您將學習如何啟用 Microsoft Defender for Cloud，以便將
這些
功能實際應用到
您的環境中。  Microsoft Defender for Cloud 整合了多項重要的
安全功能。
從開發
安全運維（DevSecOps）的
角度來看，它統一了跨多雲和多管道環境的
程式碼安全管理，
幫助安全和
開發團隊基於同一組訊號和優先順序開展工作。  從雲端安全態勢管理 (CSPM) 的
角度來看，它揭示了
您可以透過改進配置和減少暴露來防止安全漏洞的措施。
從雲端工作負載保護
平台 (CWPP) 的
角度來看，它為伺服器、容器、儲存、資料庫等常見工作負載類型提供專門的
保護。
這樣，你就可以在最關鍵的地方發現
威脅並調查可疑
活動。
在評估雲端防禦工具時，
您會注意到其功能是
按計劃組織的，通常
與姿態管理和工作負載
保護需求一致。  在
這裡，我們將了解計劃選項
和新的 CSPM 計劃矩陣，它可以
幫助您了解根據
您選擇的計劃包含哪些功能。
這一點很重要，因為啟用
正確的計劃決定了您的訂閱和連接環境可以使用哪些
控制、洞察和偵測功能
。
若要使用雲端防禦者的所有
功能（包括威脅防護），您
需要在包含要保護的工作負載的訂閱上啟用增強型安全
功能
。實際上，這意味著要進入 Azure 入口網站中的
Defender for Cloud 體驗，
並為
正確的範圍啟用正確的計畫。因此，註冊和偵測功能可以
開始
應用於該訂閱中的資源
。
啟用 Defender for Cloud 後，下一步是確保正確資產真正連接，因為您的
安全態勢和威脅訊號的完整程度取決於您正在監控的資產清單。  讓我們來看看如何連接 Azure 資源和 Azure 外部的資產。  在本模組中，您將學習如何在 Defender for Cloud 中探索 Azure 資產、設定設定和
監視入門，以及如何將 Microsoft Defender for endpoint 與 Defender for Cloud 整合。  接下來，我們將
介紹如何連接 Azure 和
非 Azure 機器，最後，我們
將介紹
如何連接 AWS 帳戶和 GCP 項目，以便您可以將安全管理擴展到多雲環境。  在這裡，我們使用資產清單來
實際了解
Defender for Cloud 正在追蹤的內容。
您可以從庫存摘要開始，其中顯示了資源總數、不健康的資源數量、未監控的資源數量，甚至顯示了它們是否已註冊訂閱。
從那裡，您可以深入了解每個資源的狀態，查看是否啟用了代理監控、是否套用了
Defender for
Cloud 保護以及與該資產關聯的建議。  隨著螢幕上的
流程動畫展示這些區域，關鍵在於庫存不僅僅是一個清單。這是一種優先考慮覆蓋範圍缺口並迅速集中精力關注需要關注的
資源的方法。  接下來，我們來看看設定。  透過安裝
正確的擴充程序，Microsoft
Defender for Cloud 可以自動將 Azure 資源甚至非 Azure 資源納入其中。啟用擴充功能後，Defender for Cloud 會透過指派安全性
原則將其安裝到新的
和現有的資源上。  這意味著您無需手動逐一操作每個虛擬機器或每個服務。
相反，您
可以在環境設定和監控配置中集中設定新使用者註冊行為，Defender for Cloud 會將其一致地應用於所選範圍。  現在，讓我們從僅使用 Azure
轉向混合雲
和多雲
。
無論您是在本地、其他雲端環境還是混合環境中運行伺服器，您仍然需要一個統一的地方來了解風險並應對威脅。而這正是將非 Azure 資產連接到
Defender for Cloud 所能實現的
。  在本模組中，我們將重點放在三個結果：將
非 Azure 機器連接到 Microsoft Defender for Cloud、
連接 AWS 帳戶以及連接 GCP 專案。這裡的想法是將相同的態勢管理和威脅防護功能擴展到 Azure 之外，以便您
可以管理整個環境中的安全性。  為了保護
非 Azure 資源，Azure Arc 發揮核心作用。  Azure Arc 透過提供一致的多雲和本地管理平台，簡化了治理和管理。
換句話說，您可以將
Azure 外部執行的伺服器和 Kubernetes 叢集投影到 Azure 管理中，然後在
所有環境中更一致地套用策略、監控和安全控制（包括 Defender for Cloud）。  連接
非 Azure 機器時，需要了解一些關鍵步驟。啟用 Azure Arc 後，您可以在非 Azure 主機上安裝 Azure 連線的機器
代理，以將它們置於 Azure Arc
管理之下
。然後，您可以使用
資料收集規則 (DCR) 透過安裝
Azure 監控代理程式（通常稱為 AMA）來啟用
監控。
您可以將連接到 Azure 的 Windows 電腦新增至 DCR 資源以安裝 AMA。  您也可以將 Arc 連線的
Linux 機器新增為 DCR 資源來安裝 AMA
。  另一個重要的整合是 Microsoft Defender for Endpoint。您可以使用直接註冊方式在租用戶層級進行註冊，在 Defender for Cloud 管理設定中啟用，然後使用標準的 Microsoft Defender for Endpoint 註冊方法。
您也可以根據目前管理監控和安全操作的方式，使用基於 Azure 入口網站的入
職方式，例如工作區層級的直接入職
。  讓我們來看看如何連接
AWS。  在
Microsoft Defender for Cloud 中啟用 AWS 帳戶時，您需要整合 AWS Security Hub。結果是，
Defender for
Cloud 現在可以跨兩個環境提供可見性和保護訊號。這樣，您就可以以更統一的方式存取姿態和表面查找功能，而無需在不同的入口網站和儀表板之間來回切換。  谷歌雲端也採用了
類似的
方法。
將您的 GCP 帳戶連接到
Microsoft Defender for Cloud 可
整合 GCP 安全性指揮中心，讓
Defender for Cloud 能夠在兩個雲端環境中運作
可見度和保護
。  一旦
您的資產連結完畢，下一個重點就是了解並改善您的整體安全狀況。讓我們
來探索
Microsoft Defender for Cloud 中的
雲端安全態勢管理功能，包括對整個環境進行評分、基準測試、建議和風險分析。  在本模組中，我們的目標是實現三個結果。首先，您將能夠描述
Defender for Cloud 安全評分。  其次，您將了解 Defender for Cloud 如何實作 Microsoft
雲端安全基準 (MCSB)。  第三，您將能夠解釋
Defender for Cloud 所應用的姿態管理保護，以幫助您降低
資源風險。
安全評分為您提供了一種可衡量的方法來了解您當前的安全狀況，並追蹤一段時間內的改進。  在這裡
，我們將了解 Defender
for Cloud 中的安全
評分體驗，其中姿態改進措施會轉化為分數。其實際價值在於確定優先順序。
您可以識別高影響力建議，了解是什麼因素導致分數上升或下降，然後將該分數用作衡量
您的互聯訂閱
和環境中姿勢改善情況的簡單、一致的指標
。  比較不同微軟服務和雲端服務中安全評分的使用情況也很有幫助。  對於 Microsoft 365 等 SaaS 服務，評分體驗是 Microsoft 安全性評分，重點關注身分、裝置和應用程式等領域，並透過 Microsoft 365 安全中心進行管理。
對於 PaaS 和 IaaS 場景，Defender for Cloud 透過 Defender for Cloud 控制面板提供安全性評分，當您連接其他雲端供應商時，您也會看到評分對應到這些生態系統。對於 AWS，姿態查找
是透過 AWS
安全中心提供的；對於 GCP，姿態查找是透過 GCP 安全
指揮中心提供的。
Defender for Cloud 將這些訊號集中在一起，以便您可以集中管理它們。  此比較也很有用，您可以選擇性地將您在課程前面可能學到的有關 Microsoft Secure Score 的知識與此處的 Defender
for Cloud Secure Score 進行比較。
建議是讓姿勢管理變得切實可行的關鍵。
在這裡，我們將查看 Defender for Cloud 中的建議
視圖，其中匯總了您可以採取的具體
步驟來降低風險，例如強化配置、解決缺失的控製或改進監控覆蓋範圍。  在處理這些建議時，您通常會根據嚴重性和影響程度確定優先級，將責任分配給合適的團隊，並將補救進度作為持續安全
營運的一部分進行追蹤。
Defender for
Cloud 也透過 Microsoft 雲端安全基準 (MCSB) 協助
您與一套公認的安全控制措施保持一致
。
當您啟用 Defender for Cloud 時，此
基準會自動指派給您的訂閱
和
帳號。它
以 Azure 安全
基準定義的雲端安全原則為基礎，並對其進行了擴展，提供了詳細的技術實施指導，不僅適用於 Azure，還適用於其他雲端供應商，如 AWS 和 GCP，甚至適用於其他 Microsoft 雲端。最終形成一個統一的控制框架，您可以利用該框架推動整個環境中的
姿態改善和合規性討論。  在此基礎上，您可以直接在
Defender for Cloud 中衡量合規性。 Microsoft
雲端安全基準是 Defender for Cloud 的預設
策略計劃，也是
您看到的各項安全建議的基礎。這意味著合規報告
和姿態建議是相互關聯的
。
在進行補救、尋找和實施控制措施的過程中，您不僅可以提高安全性評分，還可以加強與基準的
一致性，並使合規性要求與基準相符。  除了評分和檢查清單之外，
Defender for Cloud 還可以幫助您像攻擊者一樣了解身分、網路暴露、權限和資源關係的風險。
這裡我們使用攻擊路徑
分析和雲端安全瀏覽器來掃描
和查詢雲端
安全圖
。  雲端安全
圖是 Defender
for Cloud 內部基於圖的上下文引擎，它從您的多雲環境和其他來源（例如雲端資產清單、連接、資源之間的
潛在橫向移動路徑、
互聯網暴露、權限、網路連接、漏洞等）
收集資料。  這些數據用於建立代表
您環境的圖表，從而支援比孤立的警報或單一配置查找更豐富的風險分析。  攻擊路徑分析旨在揭示成功入侵所需的條件鏈。它不僅告訴你某些
東西配置錯誤，還向你展示多個弱點如何
相互連接，從而將入口點變成高價值目標
。  如果
這能提供一些修復該問題的建議，那麼就能
幫助您確定修復的優先順序，從而減少現實世界中的攻擊風險
。  雲端安全資源
管理器提供查詢
建構器體驗，以便您可以在環境中執行基於圖的查詢
。
當你想回答諸如「顯示具有高權限的
網路暴露資源」或「尋找敏感資料的路徑」之類的問題，而無需手動關聯數十個單獨的發現時，這尤其有用。查詢
體驗利用雲端安全圖來呈現帶有情境的資訊結果。
您可以使用工作簿來視覺化趨勢和營運洞察
。  這些功能為您提供了現成的儀表板，用於顯示
諸如
安全評分隨時間的變化、系統更新、漏洞評估結果、合規性隨時間的變化以及主動警報等場景。  工作簿有助於將大量安全資料轉換為更易於追蹤、報告
和與利害關係人審查的格式。  現在我們已經了解了姿態管理，接下來讓我們進入工作
負載保護，Defender for Cloud 的關注點從我們如何配置安全性轉移到我們如何
檢測和響應針對我們運行的工作負載的威脅
。  在本模組中，您將學習 Microsoft
Defender for Cloud 如何保護工作負載、這些保護措施的好處以及這些保護措施是如何運作的
。其目標是幫助
您了解不僅涵蓋哪些內容（例如伺服器、容器和儲存），還了解 Defender for Cloud 如何連接訊號、產生警報以及支援調查和修復。  對於伺服器保護，
Defender for Cloud 提供 Microsoft Defender 伺服器版方案。方案一將 Microsoft
Defender for endpoint 部署到您的伺服器
，並提供重要的好處。  Microsoft
Defender 端點版的授權是按小時收費，而不是按席位收費，如果您只是在虛擬機器運行時對其進行保護，則可以降低成本。  Defender for
endpoint 還可以自動部署到雲端工作負載，確保新工作負載在啟動時受到保護
。  來自 Defender
for endpoints 的
警報和漏洞資料會直接顯示在 Microsoft Defender for Cloud 中
，以便您可以從更統一的安全視圖進行查看。  方案二（以前簡稱為伺服器版 Defender）包含了方案一的所有優點，並增加了對另一項
Microsoft
伺服器版 Defender 功能的支援。因此，當您需要
最全面的伺服器保護功能時，這是您的首選方案。  在這裡，我們將探討如何透過
Defender for Cloud 設定
和 Defender 計畫來設定
伺服器保護。在
這裡，我們會評估伺服器庫存，看看哪些伺服器
已覆蓋。並在此處配置配置，以便部署正確的代理程式
和擴充功能。需要注意的是，如果您關閉代理程式的自動配置，則需要手動在虛擬機器上安裝 Azure 監視代理
程式。  此設定會對覆蓋範圍產生重大影響，
因此在
部署過程中值得驗證。
對於託管
在 Azure 應用
程式服務上的應用程序，Microsoft Defender for App Service 利用雲端的規模來識別針對這些應用程式的攻擊。攻擊者經常探測Web應用程序，尋找可以利用的漏洞。  在要求被路由到特定環境之前，發送到
在 Azure 中執行的應用程式的
流量會經過多個網關，請求會在這些網關中被檢查和記錄。  Defender 利用這些資料來
識別漏洞和
攻擊者，並
學習新的模式，以便日後應用這些模式來
改善偵測。
當偵測到可疑
情況時，Defender for App Service 會產生警報，您可以進行調查
和修復。
Defender for Cloud 也為資料庫提供雲端工作負載保護。其目的是檢測
可疑行為並攻擊資料庫
服務。這樣一來，
您就可以識別異常存取模式或潛在的攻擊企圖等威脅。專門針對 Azure SQL 資料庫，
Defender for Cloud 提供了一系列警報，旨在
發現這些與資料
庫相關的威脅並指導調查。  從
更廣泛的資料庫覆蓋範圍來看，Microsoft Defender for database 包含了對 Azure Cosmos DB 的威脅防護。  它也為開源關係型資料庫提供
威脅防護，包括 Azure 資料庫 Postgres、
Azure 資料庫 MySQL 和 Azure 資料庫 MariaDB。
針對每種資料庫類型，我們提供了額外的文檔，以幫助您了解檢測、入駐要求
和調查工作流程。對於開源關係型資料庫，Defender for Cloud 還提供了一組定義的警報，描述了可以偵測到哪些類型的可疑活動。  儲存是另一個高價值目標。  而 Microsoft
Defender for storage 則提供針對
可疑
存取或涉及儲存
帳戶的活動的偵測功能。當 Defender 偵測到潛在的惡意行為（例如異常存取模式）時，
它會產生
警報，幫助您調查
發生了什麼，並決定採取補救措施來降低持續存在的風險。
對於容器化環境，
Microsoft Defender for container 可
跨多個平台保護您的叢集
。這包括 Azure Kubernetes 服務 (
AKS)、
Amazon Elastic Kubernetes 服務 (
EKS)（
當它們在連接的 AWS 帳戶中執行時）以及使用
Azure Arc 啟用的 Kubernetes 連接的非託管 Kubernetes 發行版。
這種覆蓋範圍非常重要，因為
Kubernetes 叢集可以承載許多
工作負載和身份，並且能夠跨環境一致地
偵測威脅和錯誤配置
有助於
減少盲點。
Microsoft Defender for Key Vault 可偵測對 Key Vault 帳戶的
異常和潛在有害的
存取或利用嘗試。
這一層保護旨在
幫助您應對威脅，而無需
成為安全專家，也
無需部署和管理第三方
安全監控系統。
當發生異常活動時，Defender for
Cloud 會顯示警報，並且可以
選擇透過電子郵件將警報傳送給
組織中的相關人員。
這些警報包括可疑活動的詳細信息，以及
如何調查和
消除威脅的建議。
Microsoft Defender for Resource Manager
專注於 Azure 管理階層的威脅和可疑活動。
它有助於防止可疑的
資源管理操作，例如對
惡意 IP 位址的操作、試圖停用反惡意軟體
或在
虛擬
機器擴充中執行可疑腳本。
它還可以偵測 MicroBurst 或 PowerSploit 等漏洞工具包的使用情況，更
重要的是，它有助於
解決
從 Azure 管理層橫向移動
到 Azure 資源資料平面等場景，攻擊者可能會
嘗試
從控制平面存取轉向工作負載
存取。
Defender for API 可協助您了解業務關鍵型 API 的狀況，以便
您可以調查和改善
安全態勢、優先
修復漏洞並偵測 OWASP API 的主要威脅。  它提供了 Azure API 管理中發布的所有 API 的統一清單。它可以利用基於機器學習的偵測和基於威脅情報的偵測來監控 API 流量，以偵測
OWASP API 的主要威脅。
它還提供安全洞察，例如
識別未經身份驗證的 API、不
活躍或休眠的 API 以及
外部暴露的 API。它可以對接收或回應敏感資料的 API 進行分類，幫助
您將保護重點放在
業務影響最大的地方。
工作負載保護也延伸到整個開發流程。  DevOps Defender 透過中央
控制台提供
對 DevOps 安全態勢的統一可見性
。這樣，安全管理員就可以在一個地方查看 DevOps 的資產清單和狀態。它透過為基礎設施即程式碼模板和容器鏡像啟用安全性，
幫助加強整個開發生命週期中的雲端資源
配置，從而
降低
錯誤配置
進入生產環境的可能性。它還可以透過拉取請求註釋和分配開發人員所有權來幫助
優先修復程式碼中的關鍵問題
，以便
追蹤和完成修復。值得注意的是，DevOps
安全功能
已在多個地區的商業雲端中提供
，包括亞洲部分地區、澳洲、加拿大、美國、英國和
歐洲。
在這裡我們可以看到它在
實際應用上的樣子。 DevOps 安全頁面可作為中央控制台，您可以在其中
查看
所有入職環境以及
關鍵指標。這讓您可以更直觀地了解安全覆蓋範圍、安全態勢
問題
集中在哪裡，以及哪些環境可能
需要安全和開發團隊立即關注。  至此，我們已經討論了姿勢和
防護措施。
現在，我們將重點放在當 Defender for Cloud 實際偵測到可疑情況時會發生什麼。  讓我們一起來了解警報的工作原理、如何回應以及如何自動化部分修復工作流程。  在本模組中，您將學習如何在 Microsoft
Defender for Cloud 中描述警報
、如何
回應這些警報以及如何在 Defender for Cloud 中自動執行回應，以便常見的修復操作能夠持續快速地運行
。
本文重點
介紹 Microsoft Defender for Cloud 中的安全警報究竟代表什麼。當
Defender 偵測到
可能表示存在威脅的行為時，會產生
安全警報和事件。  這些檢測是基於對您環境的
持續
監控和持續安全
評估。  警報會進行分類，以幫助您了解問題的性質和嚴重程度，其內容涵蓋
從可疑活動到確認惡意行為等各種情況。了解警報類型及其產生方式是有效且一致地做出回應的
第一步
。
一旦發出警報，Microsoft Defender for Cloud 可協助您指導回應。在這裡我們可以
看到，警報如何提供
可操作的任務，幫助您減輕威脅、防止將來發生類似的攻擊，或觸發自動回應。
您也可以在適當的時候抑制警報，例如當您確認警報是誤報時。  目標是在不失去重要上下文的情況下，快速
從檢測階段過渡到
行動階段。  對於重複出現或易於理解的場景，自動化
可以顯著
縮短反應時間。本文將介紹
如何建立邏輯應用並定義其自動運行的條件。透過自動回應警報，
您可以確保即使在正常工作時間之外，也能持續、立即地採取補救措施。  並非每次警報都
需要採取行動
。當警報被識別為誤報或觸發過於頻繁而失去作用時，抑制規則非常有用。  本文將探討抑制規則如何幫助減少噪音，以便安全團隊能夠專注於真正重要的
警報，同時又不失去對整體
安全狀況的了解。  除了提供單一警報外，Defender for Cloud 還提供對威脅情報報告的存取權。這些
報告可以
包含活動群組、行動、威脅摘要等資訊。  如果可用，它們可能還包含攻擊者身分或關聯、攻擊者目標以及當前或歷史攻擊活動。您還將找到有關攻擊者的策略
、工具和程序的詳細信息，相關的入侵指標（如 URL 或文件哈希值），
受害者數據，以及緩解和補救措施的
指導。
更廣闊的背景不僅能幫助你理解發生了什麼，還能幫助你
理解為什麼這件事很重要。  在
這裡，我們將所有內容整合在一起，重點是如何
回應來自
特定 Azure 資源的警報。這包括回應 Azure Defender 的
金鑰
保管庫警報、DNS 警報和資源
管理器警報。我們還可以在這裡
管理警報、查看警報
詳情和配置自動化。  接下來，
我們將進行示範，把本學習路徑中的概念連結起來。在這裡，
我們將看到如何從偵測、調查到回應，全面使用 Microsoft Defender for
Cloud 來緩解威脅。  在此示範中，我們將
啟用 Microsoft
Defender for Cloud。我們已經打開了 Azure 門戶，現在讓我們導航到 Defender for Cloud。  我們直接在搜尋欄裡搜一下就行了。還有面向雲端的微軟 Defender。  我們現在需要做的是為我們的訂閱啟用雲端Defender。
那麼，讓我們前往管理部分下的環境設定。
以下是我們的管理團隊，包括我們的訂閱服務。
我們只需展開所有內容，選擇要啟用雲端
Defender 的訂閱。  在
訂閱範圍內，我們可以啟用像 Def​​ender CSPM 這樣的個人化方案。基礎功能始終處於開啟狀態
，但讓
我們啟用 Defender 雲端安全態勢管理。完畢。  我們也對伺服器進行同樣的操作。讓我們啟動第二個方案。
在。完畢。如果需要，
我們可以為 Defender 啟動其他套餐，
但現在，我們還是先省錢吧。  我們沒事。我們已啟用
雲端 Defender。
我們也可以點選「啟用所有方案」來開啟所有功能。
讓我們回到雲端
Defender，現在讓我們來探索一些有用的功能，例如「新增功能」按鈕，以便隨時了解雲端
Defender 的最新動態。它的變化速度非常快。  接下來，我們來審查一下我們的合規情況。  實際上，我們一個也沒有。那麼，讓我們激活它們。管理監理合規事宜
。
接下來，我們將再次選擇要啟動該合規性的位置。我們將選擇訂閱方案。  在安全策略部分，這裡列出了微軟已經為您建立的合
規性清單。它們包含在雲端防禦系統中。我們選擇 ISO 27001 2013，然後啟用它。  完畢。我們很好。  既然我們已經制定了標準，那麼讓我們來看看
該
標準帶來的建議。  我們將返回
Defender for Cloud，關閉環境設定、監管合規性，然後返回概覽。  這就是我們的建議。
現在，我們還不會看到任何建議，因為我們還沒有真正落實相關資源，而且這項政策目前正在實施中。但是，在這裡我們可以
看到微軟針對我們的雲端安全態勢管理提出的建議。  讓我們花點時間回顧一下本學習路徑中涵蓋的內容
。  我們首先研究了 Microsoft Defender for Cloud，它是一款 DevSecOps 解決方案，可統一管理跨多雲和多管道環境的安全性。
我們
探討了它如何實現
雲端安全態勢管理和雲端工作負載保護。它如何保護伺服器、容器、儲存和資料庫等工作負載，以及如何將保護擴展到混合環境，包括非 Azure 機器、AWS 和 GCP。  最後，
我們探討了
Defender for Cloud 如何透過可操作的
指導和自動回應來幫助您修復警報
。  我們的會議到此結束。繼續學習之旅的方式有很多種。我們鼓勵
您觀看
本課程中的其他視頻，或
在 Microsoft Learn (aka.ms/learn) 上搜尋您自己感興趣的主題
。